bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne l'audition de ramon
fernandez c'est le directeur général du
trésor il a été entendu la semaine
dernière par la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale sur l'évasion fiscale
l'objectif de cette commission d'enquêté
de mesurer l'ampleur de ce phénomène car
selon les chiffres la france perdrait
chaque année entre 30 et 80 milliards
d'euros de recettes par an à cause de
l'évasion fiscale alors sans plus tarder
direction la salle clémenceau poursuivre
cette audition bonne matinée à tous les
chers collègues nous accueillons
monsieur ramon fernandez directeur
général du trésor au ministère de
l'économie des finances et du commerce
extérieur et commissaire du gouvernement
auprès de l'autorité des marchés
financiers puisque nous avons reçu ce
matin président en juillet je vous
rappelle monsieur le directeur général
que conformément aux termes de l'article
6 de l'ordonance du 17 novembre 58
relatives au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires votre audition
doit se tenir sous serment et que tout
faux témoignage est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 4 134 tirs et 13
400 34-15 du co2 paie en conséquence je
vais vous demander de prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
pour ce faire
à ma droite et vous dirai je le jure que
je vous invite à faire je le jure je
vous remercie
je vais vous passez la parole pour un
exposé pour répondre je dirais aux
quelques questions que déjà rapporteur a
pu vous communiquer puis après je
passerai la parole à notre rapporteur
monsieur eric bouquet puis aux autres
membres de la commission en fonction je
dirais de l'actualité par l'antenne je
vous en prie vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président et merci de cette
de synthés invitation sur ce sujet qui
est un sujet évidemment très important
alors si vous en êtes d'accord je vais
tout d'abord vous vous présenter les
grandes lignes des missions de la
direction pour être sûr de bien
identifier qui fait quoi dans nos
différentes administrations notamment à
bercy et je me concentrerai dans mon
propos introductif sur l'état des
négociations au niveau international et
sur les sujets qui évidemment vous
intéressent le plus là la direction
générale du trésor est directement
impliqué dans plusieurs processus qui
touchent directement à ces sujets et les
agendas ont été assez chargé au cours
des derniers mois alors en quelques mots
les grandes missions de la direction
générale du trésor
première mission l'élaboration des
prévisions économiques et le conseil sur
les politiques économiques et les
politiques publiques qui touche au
domaine financier social et sectorielles
deuxième grande mission la régulation du
financement de l'économie et des
institutions intervenant en matière
d'assurance de banque et
d'investissement sur les marchés
financiers troisième mission les
négociations financières et commerciales
bilatérales et multilatérales ainsi que
l'aide publique au développement
et c'est notamment
dans ces deux derniers services
c'est-à-dire à la fois la régulation du
financement de l'économie et les
négociations financières et commerciales
bilatérales et multilatérales que l'on
trouve les agents qui participent
directement négociations sur ces sujets
qui vous intéressent et dont certains
d'ailleurs ma compagne aujourd'hui il
s'agit notamment de la régulation
financière qui se discute au g20 des
sujets prudentielles qui se discute au
conseil de stabilité financière le
financial stability board en anglais et
la négociation des standards anti
blanchiment qui se discute au sein du
gafi quatrième grande mission le soutien
à l'export et à l'investissement à
l'étranger des entreprises cinquième
grande mission la gestion de la
trésorerie et de la dette de l'état
alors sur les sujets qui vous
intéressent plus particulièrement
aujourd'hui je dirais que l'action de
notre direction se concentre notamment
sur les négociations financières
multilatérales au g20 mais aussi au gafi
un point peut-être sur le g20 un point
général pour faire un point rapide sur
l'état des discussions en cours avant le
sommet du g20 de los cabos qui se
réunira au mexique le 18 et 19 juin
vous savez que depuis le g20 de londres
et en 2009 et tout particulièrement tout
au long de l'année 2011 dans le cadre de
la présidence française du g20 le trésor
a été fortement mobilisés avec d'autres
administrations
sur la question de la régulation
financière et de la lutte contre les
juridictions non coopératives
je vais si vous me le permettez faire un
point général sur les avancées en
matière de régulation financière parce
que ce sont des thèmes qui sont très
très étroitement
et entre eux et puis je ferai un point
plus précis ensuite sur les avancées en
matière de lutte contre les juridictions
non coopératives sujets qui vous l'a qui
vous intéressent le plus sur la
régulation financière au g20 je dirais
que depuis le premier sommet fondateur
aux etats-unis fin 2008
à chaque occasion à chaque réunion du
g20 qu'elle soit au niveau ministériel
ou au niveau des chefs d'état la
régulation financière a donné lieu à des
discussions intenses et je pense pouvoir
dire qu'on a obtenu des avancées
importantes même si les observateurs
parfois peuvent penser regretter à juste
titre sans doute que les progrès soit
soit trop lent des progrès importants
avaient déjà été accomplis naturellement
avant la présidence française du g20 je
pense notamment au renforcement du cadre
prudentiel des banques avec les accords
dits de bâle iii qui ont multipliés
entre quatre et cinq fois les
obligations de fonds propres des banques
en matière de régulation des dérivés sur
les marchés de gré à gré de
l'encadrement des de la rémunération des
opérateurs de marché et aussi de lutte
contre les juridictions non coopératives
la présidence française du g20 en 2011 à
veiller à maintenir intact le niveau
d'ambition que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement s'était fixé fin 2008 qui
se résume encore assez bien je trouve
dans une des phrases du communiqué
d'octobre 2008 qui disait que tous les
acteurs produits ou marchés financiers
devaient faire l'objet d'une régulation
ou d'une surveillance appropriée je
pense que c'est un une définition qui
permet de capturer assez bien ce qu'on
cherche à faire dans le cadre de ses
travaux du g20 et à cannes
des progrès importants ont été accomplis
en ce sens les pays du g20 seront
désormais soumis à un suivi plus strict
de la bonne mise en oeuvre des décisions
prises qu'il s'agit des accords de bâle
des bonus ou des marchés
dérivés et au sein de toutes ces
institutions on a mis en place des
cadres de surveillance collectif qui
permettent de faire ce qu'on appelle en
anglais lapierre review et où chacun va
contrôler un peu ce que fait le voisin
pour être sûr que tout le monde avance
d'un pas qu'il soit à peu près
comparable ce qui est évidemment un
enjeu important
le conseil de stabilité financière de
son côté publiera annuellement un
tableau de bord pour identifier les
carences qu'ils sont observés dans la
transposition des accords de principe
qui sont conclues au niveau du g20
le g20 a également adopté un cadre
commun de traitement des institutions
financières d'importance systémique qui
implique à la fois une supervision
renforcée des nouveaux standards de
résolution des crises et des surcharges
en capital à partir de 2016 pour les
grandes banques systémiques dont une
première liste a été publiée à carnoux
et donc au delà de bâle iii les grandes
institutions financières systémiques
devront accumuler un capital
supplémentaire
quatre banques françaises font partie de
la liste des banques systémiques qui
devront respecter ses engagements
supplémentaires
le g20 s'est aussi mis d'accord sur des
principes de régulation et de
surveillance du système bancaire
parallèle le shadow banking crois que
c'est un sujet que vous regardez
également
on pourra y revenir naturellement plus
en détail sur des principes de
régulation des dérivés de matières
premières ainsi que sur des principes de
renforcement de la protection des
consommateurs et de nouveaux chantiers
de travail ont été lancés toujours à
cannes comme par exemple sur le
fonctionnement des marchés de cds les
credit default swaps ce qui défraie la
chronique
régulièrement et qui justifient d'une
régulation renforcée
enfin à cannes le conseil de stabilité
financière a été renforcée en énonçant
le principe qu'il serait doté d'une
personnalité juridique qui lui permettra
d'avoir des facilités renforcée en
matière de recrutement et d'effectivité
de ses actions c'est ce que le président
républicain kahn avait salué sous le nom
d' organisation mondiale de la finance
s'agissant de la lutte contre les
juridictions non coopératives
je dirais d'abord que le concept en tant
que tel est apparu me semble-t-il en
2009 à un moment où l'on cherchait à
déterminer et à identifier des
juridictions qui était non coopératif
dans plusieurs domaines et pas
uniquement en matière fiscale et donc ce
terme de juridictions non coopératives
englobe la lutte contre les paradis
fiscaux mais aussi la lutte contre le
blanchiment et le financement du
terrorisme et les territoires non
coopératifs en matière prudentielle la
mobilisation notamment françaises je
dois le dire a permis de maintenir ce
sujet très actif sur l'agenda des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement tous les
communiqués et on fait référence mais il
n'ya pas que de la communication il ya
aussi un soutien politique aux actions
concrètes qui permettent d'avancer dans
ces trois filières quelles que soient
les réticences que l'on peut rencontrer
ici et là et qui permettent d'avancer
dans l'éduction d'un certain nombre de
législations des réglementations de
processus de surveillance qui permettent
de vérifier l'effectivité de ces
standards internationaux et nous avons
ainsi obtenu que ces trois processus
fiscale blanchiment prudentielles
aboutissent à l'élaboration de listes
internationales auxquelles peuvent être
attachés des sanctions les institutions
financières internationales ont été
mobilisées dans ce cadre je pense
notamment aux institutions de
bretton-woods fmi et banque mondiale
mais pas seulement
les banques régionales de développement
la berd ou l'abbaye en europe ont été
mobilisés sur le sujet et elles ont été
conduites ces institutions à appliquer
des politiques en matière de
juridictions non coopératives qui exclue
de leurs financements des pays qui sont
identifiés comme étant non coopératifs
nous avons aussi mis à l'agenda le sujet
de la transparence des personnes morales
et des constructions juridiques sujet
très important et qui traverse les
différents processus que j'ai évoqués et
qui vise à assurer une meilleure
transparence de ces entités qui servent
très souvent d'écran et permettent ou
facilitent l'évasion fiscale ou d'autres
flux financiers illicites constat sujet
évidemment difficile car il touche au
droit des sociétés
mais il nous semble qu'il faut avancer
sur ce point également si l'on ne veut
pas que nos efforts menés par ailleurs
reste 20 sur les trois filières je ne
vais pas entrer dans le détail de ce qui
est engagé dans le cadre du forum
mondial
c'est à dire en matière de lutte contre
les paradis fiscaux parce que vous avez
entendu mes collègues notamment de la
direction de la législation fiscale qui
sont ceux qui participent directement à
ces travaux on pourra y revenir si vous
avez des questions parce qu'est la
direction générale du trésor travaille
avec la dlf sur ces sujets mais enfin
ils ont le son le ce sont les chefs de
file si j'ose dire et ce sont eux qui
sont à la manoeuvre
donc je vais peut-être détaillé en deux
minutes ou 3 peut-être les deux autres
processus qui implique plus directement
la direction générale du trésor
c'est à dire le volet prudentielles et
le volet blanchiment
alors sur le volet prudentielles c'est
un processus qui est conduit dans le
cadre du conseil de stabilité financière
donc le financial stability board
il se trouve que je préside
personnellement le le groupe d'experts
qui prépare les travaux des différents
échelons du fsb c'est un groupe qui a
été
mais en place en 2009 pour identifier
les juridictions non coopératives en
matière prudentielle et qui s'attache
notamment à ce que les différents pays
dispose d'une supervision efficaces de
le secteur bancaire assurantiel et de
marchés notamment s'agissant de la
capacité à échanger les informations
pertinentes dont il dispose
typiquement est ce qu'une autorité de
marché qui identifie une manipulation de
marché va pouvoir demander d'accéder à
l'information qui émanera d'une autre
autorité de marché et qui permet
d'identifier l'origine par exemple d'un
délit d'initié donc est ce que les
autorités en charge du contrôle des
banques des assurances et des marchés
ont la capacité d'accéder à
l'information auprès des institutions
homologues dans différents pays quels
qu'ils soient différents territoires qui
peuvent être à l'origine ou des
contreparties dans le cadre d'opérations
frauduleuses encore une fois en match
en matière d'échangé d'informations dans
les domaine prudentiel qui sont
élaborées par le comité de bâle par les
comités comparables qui élabore ses
normes en matière d'assurance et de
marché alors au terme de deux de nos
travaux qui sont d'ailleurs toujours en
cours et il y avait une assemblée
plénière hier à hong kong du conseil de
stabilité financière qui a acté un
certain nombre de points suite aux
travaux précédents nous sommes parvenus
à faire émerger une première liste qui a
été rendue publique au moment du sommet
de cannes et qui identifie les
territoires qu'ils soient joue
complètement le jeu soit ont des failles
dans leur dispositif mais sont en train
d'y travailler soit sont clairement
identifiées comme non coopératif ce
sujet prudentielles peut à première vue
paraître un peu éloigné des sujets
fiscaux
je ne crois pas je pense que une
supervision efficace implique que les
établissements superviser soit agréé que
les institutions chargées de leur
supervision est effectivement les moyens
de mener leur mission et d'accéder à
l'information en cas de doute sur ce
type de questions cela garantit que le
marché est sain et cela crée les
conditions d'une détection efficace des
flux financiers illicites en matière de
blanchiment
la direction générale du trésor
participe directement aux négociations
au sein du gafi vous savez que cette
instance vise à élaborer des standards
internationaux pour préserver
l'intégrité de nos systèmes financiers
et que le gafi travail sur la prévention
et la détection des flux financiers
illicites donc je ne vais pas détailler
l'ensemble des des activités de cette
instance mais je voudrais juste
souligner quelques points d'actualité
qui pourrait vous intéresser d'abord
s'agissant de de la liste des
juridictions à risque
au delà des normes qu'elle a édicté
cette instance le gafi a mis en place un
processus d'évaluation par les pairs qui
est
assez robuste et qui identifie les
juridictions qui n'ont pas de dispositif
anti blanchiment et de lutte contre le
financement du terrorisme
à l'issue de chaque réunion plénière du
gafi c'est à dire trois fois par an et
publié une liste actualisée de
juridiction qui identifie de façon
graduelle les pays en fonction de leur
défaillance une trentaine de
juridictions font actuellement l'objet
d'une identification public et d'un
suivi renforcé afin de maintenir la
pression internationale et de s'assurer
qu'elles prennent les mesures
nécessaires pour y remédier deuxième
point la révision des standards et les
travaux en cours
la plénière de février de cette année
2012 a acté deux évolutions majeures qui
vous concerne tout particulièrement
d'abord la fraude fiscale est désormais
explicitement entrer dans le champ des
infractions dont traite le gafi c'était
déjà le cas en france
c'était déjà le cas au niveau
communautaire
mais ce n'était pas encore
officiellement acté au niveau du gafi et
donc c'est une avancée importante à
laquelle la france a fortement contribué
blanchiment et fraude fiscale
aujourd'hui ne peuvent plus être
distingués c'est une novation de la
révision des standards qui date de
février 2012
deuxièmement les standards sur la
transparence des personnes morales ont
été avec le soutien là aussi active de
la france
clarifiée et renforcée comme vous avez
pu le constater la plupart des montages
de fraude ou d'optimisation fiscale
utilisent des structures opaques qui
permettent de dissimuler le bénéficiaire
réelle des fonds et ainsi de les
soustraire à l'impôt
nous avons en france un système de
registre des sociétés qui est très
complet très largement accessible qui
nous permet d'avoir aidé changé beaucoup
d'informations sur nos personne morale
ce que le gafi à noter d'ailleurs au
moment de l'évaluation de la france
mais ce n'est pas le cas de nombre
autre juridiction ce qui complique voire
empêchent de nombreuses enquêtes
fiscales ou judiciaires d'aboutir c'est
un sujet transversal très important il
doit aussi progresser au niveau du forum
mondial qui traite également de ses
sujets et le g20 a mandaté le gafi et le
cd eux pour qu'un rapport soit rendu sur
l'avancée de leurs travaux dans ce
domaine au moment du g20 de los cabos en
juin prochain
enfin dernier point sur le gafi le gafi
a mis en place un mécanisme novateur
d'examen des dispositifs nationaux de
régularisation fiscale qui conduit le
gafi a analysé dès leur mise en place
les mécanismes de ce type pour s'assurer
qu'ils ne conduisent pas à favoriser le
blanchiment de capitaux et par exemple
dispositif espagnol de rapatriement des
avoirs fera dès la plénière du mois de
juin
un examen attentif et faire l'objet si
nécessaire de recommandations aux
gouvernements espagnol et donc c'est un
processus qui est mis en place de
manière systématique
voilà en conclusion je pense que l'on
peut dire qu'avec la crise financière le
monde a pris conscience de l'importance
des sujets de régulation financière de
la nécessité qu'il ya de progresser sur
ces sujets pour limiter les risques
systémiques dans cet agenda la lutte
contre les juridictions non coopératives
a pris une place importante
encore une fois il n'y a pas de réunion
du g20 où le sujet ne soit pas évoquée
vous aurez vu au au fil des communiqués
du g20 que la pression est maintenue
pour que l'ensemble des instances
compétentes se penche sur la question et
je le dis en tant président de ce groupe
d'experts sur le volet prudentielles de
cet exercice
on voit bien que c'est un un processus
qui oblige les différentes instances
compétentes à se mobiliser sur le sujet
et a délivré des résultats puisque
il ya des processus de revue par les
pairs qui fonctionne et ce processus de
deux listings d'identification des
juridictions non coopératives a un
impact très fort qui est d'ailleurs pas
consensuels vous avez des pays dans
lesquels cette pratique qui consiste à
mettre à l'index des territoires au
motif qu'ils ne respectent pas certaines
règles
cette manière de faire n'est pas du tout
consensuelle en réalité il nous semble à
nous que c'est un processus efficace et
que la pression publique permet
d'obtenir des résultats
donc nous continuerons à peser en ce
sens ce printemps il faut être conscient
du fait que encore une fois ce sont des
des dispositifs qui n'avance que dans la
mesure où on obtient l'assentiment des
différents pays des différents états
concernés et donc c'est un processus qui
peut paraître l'an il nous paraît nous
même parfois trop lent mais il avance et
il avance dans ce cadre ou
collectivement on arrive à élaborer des
règles partagées et appropriée par les
différents territoires dont il est dont
il est question
donc les travaux vont vont continuer je
pense que vos propres travaux
permettront de mettre un accent plus
précis sur l'un des aspects de cette de
cette démarche
mais encore une fois que les sujets sont
sont liés les uns aux autres et que on a
un intérêt à maintenir une pression
collective sur ces trois volets fiscale
blanchiment prudentielles parce qu'en
réalité les trois les trois filières
permettent de croiser les informations
et d'avoir une approche plus efficace de
cette problématique
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
directeur général dont je passe la
parole à monsieur bouquet bien merci
monsieur le directeur de cette
présentation
première question sur les travaux du
gafi que vous avez évoquées qui sont
évidemment centraux dans les actions qui
doivent être menées et vous évoquez une
liste de juridiction
30 juridictions notamment et vous
parlait parfois à leur sujet d'un suivi
renforcé
est ce que vous pourriez nous expliquer
en quoi consiste ce suivi renforcé dans
le cas où des juridictions non conformes
cela alors les ce suivi renforcé
consiste à ce que vous avez un certain
nombre de groupes qui au moment de
l'identification d'un territoire comme
respectant insuffisamment un certain
nombre de standards va entrer dans un
dialogue avec les autorités du du
territoire en question pour l'inciter à
se mettre en conformité donc il ya un
certain nombre de phases dans le
processus qui permette de manière
régulière de faire le point et qui sont
une incitation très forte à ce que les
législations les réglementations
nationales soient mises à jour afin
d'être en conformité au moment de la
deuxième étape de la revue donc nous
mêmes par exemple la france a fait
l'objet d'une revue du gafi l'année
dernière c'est un exercice qui suscite
une très forte mobilisation de
l'ensemble des administrations
concernées par ce que personne ne
souhaite évidemment être identifié comme
étant comme étant défaillant et c'est
ainsi que cela se passe pour l'ensemble
des territoires dont il est question
donc vous avez vraiment un dispositif
qui fonctionne avec des examinateurs
vous avez des pays qui sont désignés
comme
les examinateurs qui vont entrer dans un
dialogue resserré avec avec les états en
question et qui vont ensuite pouvoir
rapporté devant la plénière devant le
groupe pourra tester ou pas de la mise à
jour des des différents pays ensuite
vous avez évoqué comme ligne d'action
souhaité d'inscrire à l'agenda la
nécessaire transparence des personnes
morales et non vous évoqué à ce propos
l'existence d'entités écran dont on
connaît effectivement l'existence
comment appréhendez vous ces sociétés
ces entités écran quels sont vos moyens
vos méthodes pour appréhender cette
particularité et pensez vous que la
réflexion actuelle sur le l'éventuel
renforcement de la réglementation
communautaire
à ce sujet je pense à l'enregistrement
des trusts et sociétés par exemple est
ce que vous pensez c'est ce que
réflexion pourrait aboutir une réponse
utile en matière de prix si on est dans
un processus qui est comme je le disais
en phase de montée en puissance le g20
je pense que la commande a été passée en
février au g20 ministériel qui s'est
tenue au mexique de faire rapport à l'
ocde notamment sur sur ce type de
processus qui permettent de voir de
quelle manière les trusts et ses
structures opaques permettait de
renforcer les dérives les dérives du
système
alors comme je le disais nous avons un
système de registre des sociétés
publiques en france qui limite ce type
d'abus mais dans d'autres territoires
ce type de disposition n'existe pas donc
je pense qu'ici on amorce un processus
qui va permettre d'identifier les
problèmes de manière beaucoup plus
claire qui ne suscite pas non plus pour
être franc un enthousiasme considérable
chez un certain nombre de nos
partenaires qui héberge des structures
comme celle ci est donc je pense que ça
va être un processus qui va prendre un
peu de temps ou le g20 précisément va
servir à ça quand quand vous êtes dans
une réunion avec des chefs d'état des
ministres des banques centrales des
fonctionnaires qui propose de mettre
l'accent sur ce type de réflexion
vous avez une pression collective pour
avancer qui est très forte c'est à ça
que sert notamment le g20 parfois que
donne le sentiment d'aller à
suffisamment vite mais typiquement le
mandat de travail qui a été donnée sur
ce sujet au gafi à l' ocde en ce début
d'année est une novation
il permet de dire explicitement et c'est
accepté par tous les pays qui sont
autour de la table que c'est un sujet
qu'il faut regarder pour voir s'il
présente des risques particuliers qui
est le type de décision il faut prendre
pour essayer d'y remédier donc je pense
que sur ce point à ce stade il est un
peu tôt pour dire ce qui pourra sortir
de ces de ces travaux mais
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que pour la
première fois le sujet des trusts
notamment des fiducie sont des sujets
qui vont être regardés et qui vont être
décortiqués par à la fois l' ocde qui
avait déjà beaucoup travaillé sur la
question et le gafi pour voir quelles
conclusions de politiques publiques
il faut en tirer au terme de du
diagnostic qui sera fait quel est le
niveau de représentation de la france au
sein du gafi est ce que votre direction
par exemple est associée à ces travaux à
un moment donné de la réfection des
digues et filles oui bien sûr c'est le
en termes concrets le la délégation est
le plus souvent dirigées par le chef du
bureau compétent de la direction
générale qui est au sein du service des
affaires multilatérales et donc il ya un
contact et un dialogue très régulier
vous savez que on a par ailleurs parfois
envoyés si j'ose dire ou eu des
ressortissants qui ont occupé des
fonctions importantes au sein du
secrétariat général notamment du gafi
ceci est dû au fait de notre implication
forte dans le déroulement des travaux et
qui se conjuguent à des discussions
interministérielles ou avec d'autres
services qui sont en charge je pense
notamment à jean baptiste carpentier et
traque fin on a un processus
interministériel des changes qui
mobilise d'autres ministères d'autres
structures administratives et qui
peuvent apporter leur contribution à ces
réflexions est ce qui vous arrive d'être
personnellement impliqués dans ces
travaux vous tant que directeur pas en
n'allant pas en tant que participant aux
réunions du gafi elle même mais plutôt
par le canal des travaux préparatoires à
l'éco fine lorsque ces sujets sont
abordés notamment au comité économique
et financier
évidemment les travaux du g20 et parfois
en marge d'autres d'autres événements
par exemple à washington en avril
en marge de la réunion des ministres de
finances du g20 il y à une cérémonie
justement pour mettre l'accent
un accent politique et le ministre des
finances de l'époque s'est rendu à 7 à
cette manifestation
pour acter la révision des standards
justement il leur donnait la pleine
force donc je ne vais pas à titre
personnel aux réunions du gafi ce sont
les services de la direction qui s'y
rendent et c'est le carde d'ailleurs
dans les autres dans les autres
structures administratives des pays qui
participent au gafi mais on a l'occasion
d'en parler à mon niveau dans les
enceintes que j'ai évoquées pour aborder
le volet prudentielles dans votre exposé
quels sont les enseignements du groupe
de supervision prudentielle puisque il
semblerait que sur la liste des mauvais
élèves prudentielles il n'y aurait que
deux pays à ma connaissance mais dit
elle est élevée les huées l'un est ce
que c'est exact et si oui est ce que
c'est bien crédible alors dons dans le
cadre de cet exercice on a examiné dans
un premier temps 60 et une juridiction
qui sont qui ont été classées par rende
system is it est à dire qu'on a classé
les juridictions internationales en
fonction de leur importance systémique
parce qu'elles étaient des pays
accueillant des activités financières en
matière bancaire d'assurance ou de
marché qui était significative on a
ensuite examiné la manière dont ces
différents territoires respecter les
standards du comité de bâle en matière
bancaire
et des comités frère si j'ose dire en
matière d'assurance et de marché et on a
classé les différents les différents
étant dans différentes catégories
il est un certain nombre de pays comme
la france qui ont été clairement reconnu
comme respectant l'ensemble des
standards dont il était question il y en
a douze d'autres qui n'étaient pas en
conformité avec au moins un des douze
standard et donc il suffisait de il
suffit de ne pas respecter au moins un
des douze standard pour être identifiés
comme présentant un défaut potentiel de
mise de mise en oeuvre et les il y avait
un peu moins de vingt dix huit pour être
précis dix huit juridictions qui était
dans cette liste qui est une sorte de
liste grise qui ne sont pas des
territoires qu'on a choisi d'identifier
comme étant non coopératif
parce qu'ils aient exprimé une volonté
de coopération et de donc ce sont des
pays des territoires qui de manière
volontaire ont indiqué s'inscrire dans
la liste de ceux qui se prêterait au jeu
d'un examen approfondi avec les équipes
du fonds monétaire international de la
banque mondiale ou d'un groupe de
travail spécifique mis en place à cet
effet par le conseil de stabilité
financière et donc vous avez des pays
qui par exemple la chine était
initialement dans cette liste
intermédiaire
a accompli un très gros travail dit de f
sap financial secteur et c'est ce même
programme avec le fmi qui a conclu qu'en
réalité la chine respectait l'ensemble
de ses standards et donc la chine basse
dans la catégorie numéro un et vous avez
effectivement une liste qui était
réduite à la portion congrue mais il ne
faut pas s'attacher qu'à cette distance
là en réalité ces listes du milieu la
plus intéressante la liste entre
guillemets de ceux qui disent ne pas
vouloir coopérer
en réalité il n'est même plus qu'un état
c'est le venezuela
la libye a bénéficié d'une sorte de on a
on à donner le bénéfice du doute aux
nouvelles autorités libyennes qui je
crois
objectivement doivent disposer d'un tout
petit peu de temps avant de deux
s'engager dans ce processus le venezuela
en revanche n'a pas exprimé de démarche
n'a pas souhaité s'engager dans ce
dialogue et qui témoigne d'une volonté
de ceux de se mettre en conformité et à
une date à déterminer
donc le venezuela aujourd'hui est seul
sur cette liste et fait l'objet d'une
disons de mesures supplémentaires de la
part du conseil de stabilité financière
qui vont alerter les autorités notamment
prudentielles sur le fait que ce pays ne
manifeste pas la volonté de ils ont
d'entrée dans ce dialogue donc nous nous
espérons collectivement que ce sera le
cas mais encore une fois je pense que ce
qui est important c'est que c'est un un
processus qui conduit l'ensemble des
pays dont on constate que à leur corps
défendant parfois ils ne respectent pas
l'ensemble de ses standards à s'engager
dans ce dialogue a amendé leur
législation leur réglementation pour se
mettre en conformité
et donc c'est un fonds que c'est un
dispositif qui fonctionne de manière si
j'ose dire préventive le fait que vous
n'ayez pas une liste noire avec quinze
états ne signifie pas que le processus
est un échec
il signifie que vous avez déclenché une
mobilisation d'acteurs
des superviseurs des législateurs des
gouvernements qui font en sorte que là
où il est il là où il y avait des
failles ses failles soit corrigée pour
justement éviter de se trouver
d'une certaine manière stigmatisé par
l'identification dans le cadre de ces
listes et quels sont les standards pour
la gestion cette liste sont les requis
je pense à la transparence par exemple
sur la la présence de trust
éventuellement est ce que ça fait partie
des obligations des préconisations ont
fait les obligations alors je vous
transmettrai monsieur rapporte hall et
les douze la liste précise de ces de ses
standards qui sont d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui en train d'être complété le
comité de bâle il n'ya peut-être de moi
à compléter la liste de ses standards en
matière d'échangé d'informations et donc
on examinera aussi désormais la
conformité des différents états à ses
standards
au regard de cette liste complétée et le
comité international de qui est en
charge de la supervision des entreprises
d'assurances est engagé dans le même
dans le même processus donc ce sont des
standards qui vérifie par exemple que
les opérateurs financiers sont soumis à
des obligations d'agrément préalable à
l'exercice des activités en question que
il y à des processus de vérification
notamment des compétences de
l'expérience des dirigeants qui lie à la
possibilité pour une autorité de
supervision d'exercer un contrôle en
ayant accès à l'information
nécessaire que les superviseurs ont la
possibilité juridique et même
l'obligation d'échanger l'information
alors que dans certains cas un
superviseur peut dire je suis
juridiquement dans l'impossibilité de
vous donner cette information parce
qu'elle est couverte par tel ou tel
secret professionnel donc ces standards
vérifie pour l'essentiel est pour
l'instant on s'attache essentiellement
on s'attache à contrôler ses standards
qui sont des standards d'échangé
d'informations qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
deux barrières qu'ils soient le fait
d'une interdiction d'échanger de
l'information
si les superviseurs ne peuvent pas
échangé à l'information
ils ne peuvent pas aller chercher
l'origine de telles ou telles fraudes ou
délits
encore une fois on est on est on est
dans le champ prudentielles dans ce dans
ce dans ce domaine là
une dernière question avant de passer la
parole à un collègue qui souhaitent
s'exprimer
est ce que vous pourriez préciser ce que
représente exactement le phénomène de
shadow banking qui a été cité et qui est
cité régulièrement et notamment les
opportunités d'évasion fiscale
internationale qu'il peut recéler alors
le sujet général du shadow banking est
un sujet qui est liée au renforcement
très puissant de la réglementation dans
le secteur bancaire le constat c'est que
depuis 2009 on a considérablement
renforcé les obligations qui pèsent sur
les banques
je pense aux obligations de fonds
propres encore une fois elles auront été
multipliées par au moins cinq mais
parfois plus pour les institutions
identifié comme étant systémique
on a mis en place des règles
contraignantes
par exemple en termes de rémunération
des opérateurs de marché qui ont été
transposées en droit interne français
par un certain nombre de textes y
compris réglementaire avec des pouvoirs
intrusif donner à l'autorité de contrôle
prudentiel de verifix et standards sont
respectées
donc dans toute une série de domaines et
ce sera le cas aussi en matière de
supervision ce sera le cas en matière de
résolution des banques
on a renforcé le contrôle sur les
banques le le problème est que en
faisant cela on renforce les incitations
à dériver un certain nombre d'activités
de nature bancaire vers des acteurs qui
ne sont pas des acteurs bancaires et qui
donc ça peut être une gauche ça peut
être un trust ça peut être une compagnie
d'assurance ça peut être un hedge fund
ça peut être un fonds de gestion
collective
si on ne prête pas garde à avoir des
règles qui soient en tout cas
compatibles entre elles ou à minima
comparables on créera une formidable
incitation à dérives et un certain
nombre de pratiques et d'activités d'un
domaine vers l'autre et donc c'est ça
l'origine des travaux sur le shadow
banking
c'est d'ailleurs un travail qui a été
impulsée notamment à notre initiative à
l'occasion d'une assemblée plénière du
conseil de stabilité financière qui se
tenait en octobre 2010 en corée je m'en
souviens fort bien quand nous avons dit
il faut traiter ce sujet au début on
nous a regardé un peu bizarrement
quel est le sujet bon aujourd'hui et ça
a été entérinée dans le cadre de la
présidence française du g20 l'année
dernière et ça fait l'objet de travaux
qui ont été discutées hier encore une
fois hong kong dans le cadre de la
plénière du fsb le communiqué de presse
qui est sorti ce matin en attestent on a
et on progresse c'est complexe puisque
l'on traite d'opérateurs québec qui sont
des opérateurs le plus souvent réguler
mais qui justifient d'une régulation qui
est différente
je pense aussi aux activités de
titrisation qui est une activité
importante qui relève de ceux de ce
domaine
mais qui peuvent présenter des
différences par exemple en termes de
contraintes qui pèsent sur la
solvabilité et la liquidité la
rémunération des opérateurs
donc ça c'est l'essentiel des travaux en
cours sur le shadow banking
il y aura évidemment des interactions
possibles avec ce qui ce qui vous
intéresse
mais aujourd'hui la problématique n'est
pas nécessairement concentrer sur ce
sujet là notamment dans la mesure où
toute une série de ces opérateurs sont
encore une fois par ailleurs réguler et
donc notamment la réglementation la
législation en matière de lutte contre
le blanchiment s'applique aussi bien à
des opérateurs qui ne sont pas des
opérateurs bancaires que à des
opérateurs strictement strictement
bancaire donc c'est un c'est un axe de
programme qui permettra aussi de d'avoir
un oeil sur les problématiques d'évasion
fiscale ou de fraude qui n'est pas le
fait générateur de cette réflexion mais
qui de manière générale consiste à
vérifier que la sphère bancaire n'est
pas la seule à justifier d'une attention
forte des régulateurs et des
superviseurs pour éviter que tout ce qui
en réalité peut créer un problème pour
le système financier dans son ensemble
pour éviter que ceux-ci ne ne partent
vers d'autres domaines qui seraient
régulés mais qui encore une fois ce raid
et des opportunités disons pour des des
activités qui seraient mieux réguler
dans le secteur bancaire est très
concrètement quelle est la part de du
shadow banking dans l'ensemble des flux
financiers quels types d'opérations sont
impliqués dans le shadow banking 15
opérateurs par exemple est ce que vous
pourriez illustré d'exemples concrets
je vais essayer de vous retrouver sur le
rapporteur 1
un diagramme un graphique je ne sais pas
comment le qualifier qu'on nous avait
présenté à l'occasion d'une des réunions
du fonds monétaire international qui
montrait et donc j'ai pas forcément des
deux chiffres avec moi mais je vous les
ferez passer plus tard qui montrait la
part relative des différents centres
financiers entre les activités bancaires
stricto sensu et le shadow banking et
c'est très intéressant c'était des
petits ballons et donc vous aviez la
balle de golf vous avez le ballon de
foot et puis on voit que la taille des
centres financiers différés
fondamentalement ou souvent très
largement selon que l'on essayé de
capturer ce shadow banking ou qu'on se
concentrer uniquement sur le secteur
bancaire
encore une fois shadow banking ne veut
pas dire que ce sont des activités qui
échappe à toute forme de régulation ou
qui sont en soi répréhensible
la gestion collective
les opcvm par exemple sont division sont
des activités périphériques et de ce
point de vue est bien une place par
exemple comme le luxembourg avec ses je
crois 1700 milliards d'euros sous
gestion
c'est une place très importante
encore une fois qu'ils ne présentent pas
nécessairement de difficultés mais qui
si on ne veille pas à avoir des
réglementations qui soit comparable
homogène ou qui peut créer des questions
les activités de titrisation de la même
manière si elles ne sont pas encadrées
peuvent créer des problèmes
les activités des fonds à effet de
levier des 'hedge fund' typiquement sont
localisés dans des centres financiers
qui ne sont pas nécessairement la ville
dans laquelle nous parlons aujourd'hui
donc il y à il ya des chiffres tout
dépend des définitions que l'on que l'on
retient mais ce sont évidemment des
multiples bien souvent des activités
qu'ils sont
uniquement identifié par les flux de
banque à banque
madame beauchamp ancien directeur du
trésor merci de votre explication et de
la mobilisation de vos équipes
moi j'ai une question assez simple en
apparence à poser concernant la méthode
nous sommes je dirais pas famille en
tout cas au quotidien de vos méthodes de
travail au sein du gafi nous les je
crois que personne ici il n'y a
participé de façon concrète on en a une
connaissance dire l ivresse coup ici
nous on imagine un petit peu ça comme
une démarche qui s'apparenterait à des
normes du type iso 9001 2008 de
management par la qualité c'est à dire
avec des auditeurs internationaux
vous êtes audités vous fournissez le
pays est audité fourni lui même les
preuves de sa bonne volonté sur les
douze standard et ensuite on imagine que
c'est évalué pour chacun des standards
et ensuite on imagine aussi que les pays
se fixent des objectifs tous ne partent
pas du même point et donc qu'il y a des
des objectifs qui peuvent être
différents suivant qu'on est un pays on
va dire qu'il n'ya pas trop de souci
avec ces questions et peut-être un pays
dans les usages serait peut-être à
s'éloigner de d'une politique très
transparente et très rigoureuse et je
voulais à ce propos la montée en fait si
tout ce qui s'est mis en place n'est pas
plus un début une un commencement
quelque chose et qui devra dans un
second temps débouché sur sur peut-être
d'autres méthodes d'autres techniques
puisque vous l'avez bien dit ce n'est
pas parce qu'il n'y a plus que deux pays
sur la liste voir le le venezuela que
tout est pour le mieux dans le meilleur
des mondes donc la question serait la
suivante compte tenu de votre expérience
qu'à la très grande de ces méthodes
contenu de votre connaissance de ses
dossiers
quel serait pour l'avenir des pistes de
réflexion pour poursuivre à l'échelle
internationale une lutte effective dans
ce domaine à ses dires pas tant le passé
vous avez vraiment exposés de façon très
convaincante est très clair notre
question serait plutôt une question
prospective si on devait se projeter
dans dix ans
compte tenu de tout ce qui a été fait
qu'est-ce qu'il resterait à faire selon
vous on a bien senti
tant sur les trusts que le shadow
banking et une tension que vous avez
bien mentionné entre l'intention des
gouvernants qui est grande
et l'empressement des acteurs qui
semblent plus mesuré je vous remercie
je pense que le premier point pour
répondre à votre question
même le sénateur c'est de dire on a
besoin d'une mobilisation politique
permanente
on a eu dans le passé des processus
comparables notamment au gafi avec ou en
matière fiscale avec des listes qui
permettait de mettre une pression
publique sur un certain nombre de
territoires et qui les incitaient à
prendre les mesures qui permettait de
sortir de ces listes et puis au fur et à
mesure du temps la pression se relâche
on passe à autre chose
et finalement tout le monde soit il ya
plus de liste et on fait des exercices
qui disent on ne ne sont plus sous
l'oeil politique vigilant des autorités
les plus élevées et donc son d'exercice
qui associe des fonctionnaires qui sont
ils sont mobilisés sur ces questions
mais qui risquent de s'arrêter si josi
au niveau des fonctionnaires alors c'est
très bien au niveau des fonctionnaires
seulement aussi a pas de pression
politique après pour changer une loi
pour faire respecter un standard
évidemment ça marche pas et donc de ce
point de vue la grande vertu du gerin
encore une fois c'est de faire en sorte
que ces questions de régulation
financière de manière générale mais
notamment ces questions de juridictions
non coopératives soient traitées au
niveau le plus élevé je crois que la
presse à l'époque avait raconté comment
le sommet de londres en avril 2009
s'était déroulée comment quelques chefs
d'état avaient dû avoir des
conversations parallèle avec des
suspensions de séance pour essayer de se
mettre d'accord sur justement le fait de
retrouver une méthode qui passait par
une identification public des
territoires qui ne jouait pas les règles
du jeu
c'était très difficile parce qu'encore
une fois je pense que dans notre pays on
a du mal à d'ailleurs moi je me j'ai
toujours un peu du mal et me faire parce
que chez nous je pense qu'il est assez
naturel de dire que ce qu'on appelle en
anglais le name and shame ça marche
vous montrez que vous
vous désignez un territoire on dira ce
territoire jouent pas le jeu c'est pas
bien c'est pas consensuelle du tout vous
avez toute une
et c'est pas c'est pas déshonorant
d'ailleurs vous avez des des partenaires
de la france qui sont des partenaires
très respectable mais qui partent d'une
logique différente qui sont des
territoires coopérative qui sont
impliqués dans ces démarches mais qui
vous disent on n'obtiendra pas de
résultat comme ça il faut discuter il
faut discuter entre nous et on obtiendra
plus de résultats comme ça ici on
stigmatise en réalité on aura on
n'obtiendra pas de résultats et au
contraire on risque de reculer parce que
les uns et les autres vont se replier
sur leurs bases et refusé d'entrer dans
ses dialogues et c'est en réalité par le
dialogue que l'on fera progresser bon ce
qui se fait aujourd'hui au niveau
international c'est une
c'est une tentative de compromis entre
ces deux approches qui abouti notamment
à la question que vous m'avez posé sur
les juridictions non coopératives en
matière prudentielle
mais pourquoi diable n'y at il que deux
états la réponse à ça c'est en réalité
il y en a beaucoup plus que deux il ya
61 états qui ont été scrutés à la loupe
et il y en a une trentaine ou une
quarantaine qui ont été clairement
identifiées comme n'étant pas
complètement en phase mais qu'on va
éviter de désigner comme étant non
coopératif parce qu'ils ne sont pas non
coopératif ils disent aujourd'hui je
reconnais que je ne respecte pas tous
ces standards je le reconnais mais ce
n'est pas une volonté de non coopération
c'est simplement un état de fait soit
les licitation évoluer les standards et
vont évoluer il faut que j'aie le temps
de m'adapter et c'est uniquement au
terme d'un processus que l'on constate
qu'il ya une mauvaise foi une mauvaise
volonté et à ce moment là qu'on
identifie c'est typiquement le cas d'un
des états qu'on a cité tout à l'heure ça
peut être le cas d'autres états qui sont
dans la zone du mouliot mais qui au bout
d'un moment rebascule dans la mauvaise
liste parce qu'ils ont un délai ils ont
un délai pour se mettre en conformité et
au terme de ce délai s'ils ne font rien
et bien le
doute ne bénéficie plus aux territoires
au territoire en question donc
aujourd'hui on a pour passer au gafi 17
pays qui sont sur la liste noire qui
sont des pays qui sont clairement
identifiées comme non coopératifs en
matière de lutte contre le blanchiment
et le financement du terrorisme
ça suscite beaucoup de débats vous avez
des pays d'ailleurs qui sont parfois
membres du g20 dans ces listes et qui
donc doivent s'expliquer auprès de leurs
de leurs partenaires donc qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire pour l'avenir à mon
avis faut qu'on continue qu'on continue
à maintenir cette pression politique
qu'on continue à maintenir cette
pression évidemment via l'ensemble de
ses processus de revue et que l'on
investit sur ces revues par les pairs
qu'on investisse du temps qu'on
investisse de l'énergie qu'on investisse
aussi du temps de fonctionnaires des
autorités de supervision de régulation
du trésor de la direction de la
législation fiscale qui doivent pouvoir
être détachés dans des groupes d'experts
qui vont passer du temps à évaluer les
autres pays et à pouvoir identifier les
défaillances pour qu'elle puisse être
corrigé donc nous nous faisons partie
parfois deux des équipes qui sommes
chargés d'évaluer la performance des
autres
c'est aussi pour ça par exemple que je
préside ce groupe d'experts sur le la
filière prudentielles voilà il faut que
tout le monde
se mobiliser que l'on maintienne ses
sujets à l'ordre du jour du g20 et au
niveau politique et la réunion de
washington le mois dernier qui a permis
de re confirmé le mandat de renouveler
le mandat du gafi c'est aussi le moyen
de 2 de maintenir la pression
voilà mais sinon je pense qu'on a les
outils techniques pour l'essentiel même
si certains doivent être complétés
notamment sur les trusts dépit du si les
structures opaques ou là on est dans des
mondes qui sont un peu moins bien
identifiés aujourd'hui ça prendra du
temps mais sur le reste on a 40
recommandations du gafi qui sont très
claires et à l'aune desquels on va
examiner la conformité des régimes
juridiques des différents états et non
seulement des régimes juridiques mais
aussi de la pratique et c'est ce que je
pense on vous a expliqué sur la filière
des deux fiscal le forum global à sa
phase 1 sa phase 2 on regarde d'abord la
lettre des textes
est-ce que vous avez un régime juridique
qui permet de lutter contre la fraude
fiscale etc et ensuite on passe à la
phase 2 qui est la lettre c'est bien
mais quelle est la pratique et donc si
vous ne passez pas en face d'eux c'est
que la lettre n'était pas conforme et
donc vous avez une pression assez forte
pour vous adapter
monsieur pilet oui merci beaucoup vous
c'était très très très intéressant les
propos vous avez porté sur les avancées
en matière de transparence des personnes
morales je me pose une question quels
sont les axes comment peut-on classer
les axes dans lesquels on pourrait
replacer ces avancées ce que par exemple
est-ce que c'est plutôt sur le mot
générisation du droit des sociétés ou
est-ce que c'est plutôt sur des mâts
mise en place d'obligations publicitaire
de publicité d'information en quelque
sorte est-ce que c'est plutôt des
avancées en matière en amont ou en aval
et si celle ci c'est le cas à votre avis
quelles sont les avancées font en tout
cas par quels axes technique
peut-on avancer le plus plus vite et
après par quels vecteurs on protège ses
avancées est ce que ces seconds des
engagements unilatéraux ce que c'est des
conventions bilatérales
est-ce que c'est des conventions
multilatérales internationales
comment pragmatiquement mettons en place
des règles qu'ils puissent savoir une
sanction autre que purement morale alors
ce stade il y a aujourd'hui dans les
standards du gafi deux recommandations
qui porte sur ces sujets qui touchent la
transparence des personnes morales et
des trusts et ce sont des
recommandations qui impose notamment que
chaque état et les moyens d'obtenir
l'information requis sur le bénéficiaire
effectif des personnes morales
enregistrées sur l'or sur leur
territoire où on voit que c'est un sujet
important parce que les trusts les
personnes morales les sociétés écrans
sont bien souvent impliqués dans des
dans des montages de fraude fiscale pour
pour dissimuler l'identité du
bénéficiaire effectif
et pour éviter de faire apparaître le
lien avec l'assujettissement call donc
on ad nous comme je le disais tout à
l'heure on a des systèmes aujourd'hui en
france avec le registre des sociétés
publiques qui sont qui sont très
complets on ad'autres d'autres pays dans
lesquels ces registres sont sont
beaucoup moins complet et dont l'accès
sur tout est extrêmement difficile donc
un premier sujet qui est de
de d'utiliser pleinement les
recommandations et de faire respecter
les recommandations qui sont aujourd'hui
existantes parmi les 40 recommandations
du gafi
parce qu'aujourd'hui ces recommandations
elles sont très mal respectée donc c'est
ça je pense là la priorité faire en
sorte que dans le cadre des travaux du
gafi dans le cadre de la révision des
standards qui qui ont été qui ont été
effectués on puisse se concentrer sur
ces sujets encore une fois ça n'a pas
été toujours très facile parce que
certains états
je vais pas les citer mais n'ont pas été
disons très très très enthousiaste parce
qu'ils sont assez conscients de des
limites de leurs propres systèmes
nationaux et sur les trusts c'était
encore plus compliqué pour les mêmes
pour les mêmes raisons ne voulez-vous
pas les sites est monsieur fernandez
je ne sais pas monsieur le rapporteur
jeu je vous bas parce que quand on est
gosse parce que dans le cadre de des
négociations l'habitude n'y est plutôt
d'éviter de mai la question autrement
quels sont les alliés de la france dans
ce combat oh vous avez
vous avez des alliés qui peuvent se
trouver souvent en europe mais aussi
dans des pays des pays émergents et en
développement je pense par exemple à
l'inde qui est ou qui est très active
sur sur ces sujets vous avez des pays
qui sont les états unis sont assez
coopératif en dépit du fait que le
dollar ware est clairement identifiée
parfois comme me facilitaient tu mets
des états unis jouent le jeu
bon vous avez d'autres d'autres d'autres
états qui sont encore une fois un tout
petit peu moins enthousiaste encore une
fois je reviens à ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur cette démarche qui consiste
à essayer de progresser tous ensemble
ces exercices sont des exercices qui
fonctionne d'autant mieux que on arrive
à se convaincre collectivement que c'est
que c'est notre intérêt de 2 d'avancé
donc on a ces recommandations on va voir
l'exercice qui a été engagé avec le
gaffer l'oscd eux qui vont être des des
juges de paix extérieur qui pourront
dire on regarde l'examen des textes
voilà telle ou telle structure qui
facilite un certain nombre de dérives et
sur cette base je pense qu'on pourra
avoir une discussion intéressante et
qu'on pourra qu'on pourra on pourra
progresser il faudra d'ailleurs
progressé en faisant jouer les synergies
entre les différents groupes dont il est
question parce que typiquement entre le
gafi le forum global
vous avez des interactions et il est
utile que ces différents forums se
répondent et donc les lunes de nos l'une
de nos tâches c'est aussi au sein de
l'administration de veiller dans nos
différentes filières si j'ose dire que
l'information circule et je dois dire
qu'on se parle très souvent notamment
avec la direction de la législation
fiscale pour bien coordonner nos
positions échanger l'information entre
nous aussi sur l'évolution des des
standards dans les différents dans les
différents groupes
mais les choses je voudrais pas laisser
penser que rien n'avance y compris sur
ce sujet par exemple on a on a obtenu
dans le cadre de ces discussions que les
pays qui crée des trusts impose dans
leurs lois des obligations de
transparence pour ces entités qui sont
créées selon leurs propres droits mais
des obligations de transparence et donc
c'est un c'est un chemin qui est qui et
qui est difficile qui est long mais dans
lequel à force de 2,2 de discussions et
de cette pression qui à chaque fois
réuni les différents états qui se
trouvent autour de cette table
permettent permettent d'avancer
et puis los cabos je leur dis mais je
pense que c'est important on aura à los
cabos donc le sommet du g20 au mexique
le 18 19 juin on aura un rapport qui
sera remis sur la table des chefs d'état
parle ocde et le gafi
quand est ce que vous vous rendez votre
avant l'accord important de nous
soumettre son propre app alors qu'il
sera inspiré alors que l'efficacité
d'une dose on pourra vous de transmettre
dès que dès que nous les recevons nous
vous le nouveau le transmettrons je suis
pile est encore petite pression la
france se montrant fort heureusement
leader
dans ces opérations comment il reste
deux de transparence
ma question vous gênera peut-être un
petit peu moins est ce que il y à une
hiérarchie ce que vous pouvez dire si
annie hiérarchie des états européens
dans l'intensité coopérative est ce que
l'angleterre eux est très très
coopérative est ce que l'italie les plus
part de la hiérarchie européenne parce
que peut-être est-il plus facile de
penser que les progrès se feront plus
vite au sein de notre communauté
coco niveau mondial donc est ce qu'il ya
des freins au sein de notre propre
communauté
oui pour compléter on sent très bien
dans votre intervention la dimension
internationale obligatoirement de du
sujet qui nous préoccupe en rond sans
également aux quoi on a le plus tôt la
perception que on est un petit peu un
tournant des initiatives ont été prises
dans le g20 il puis veut par exemple les
accords rubik ou d'un côté il ya eu une
impulsion et puis d'un autre côté on
voit deux grands partenaires européens
peut-être suivie par d'autres qui vont
je dirais contrecarrer ces impulsions
c'est un peu ça c'est dans le domaine
fiscal
mais on sent que sur un certain nombre
de sujets la dimension internationale
pour l'instant il ya plusieurs voies qui
peuvent être prises et on ne sait pas si
notre pays est isolé au sein des
partenaires européens puisque je sais
c'est la dimension européenne qui nous
préoccupe
ou si au contraire on va pouvoir
entraîner et renforcer cette position
c'est valable sur la fiscalité en tout
cas je pense sont les accords rubik sur
le gafi l'une des questions qui nous
était posée c'est les membres du gafi
puisque je crois que le défi n'accepte
pas d'autres adhésions
en attendant que
on discute avec la communication pour
élargir mais parmi les 27
on n'est pas tous membres du gafi à moi
donc c'est l'une des questions qui nous
a été régulièrement posée également dans
dans les auditions donc sur cette
dimension internationale est ce que
notre positionnement positionnement du
gouvernement français a une position
centrale où nous risquons un isolement
je crois monsieur le président qu'on est
sur une position qui est un peu en
avance de la position centrale
nous ne sommes pas isolés bien sûr les
européens sont le plus souvent membres
d'une des organisations alors parfois
vous avez l'institution centrale si
j'ose dire
le gafi le le conseil de stabilité
financière où la plupart des pays
européennes sont membres et puis par
défaut vous avez des groupes régionaux
qui sont mis en place et qui permettent
de d'associer ce qui ne serait pas
membre du du groupe du groupe central
les européens de manière générale et
notamment les européens continentaux
sont
sont mobilisés sur ces sujets je pense à
plusieurs pays coeur de la zone euro qui
sont qui sont mobilisés sur ces sujets
les etats unis sont mobilisés sur ces
sujets des grands pays émergents sont
mobilisés sur ces sujets j'ai parlé de
l'inde mais par exemple en matière de
lutte contre les paradis fiscaux vous
avez d'autres états d'amérique latine
qui sont qui sont aussi fortement
mobilisés donc la france est pas isolé
bien sûr elle porte un message un peu
plus exigeant qu'à moyenne je dirais et
en fonction des sujets vous pouvez
parfois avoir des partenariats qu'ils
ont plus fort dans un domaine que dans
l'autre enfin vous avez quand même une
approche générale qui est le plus
souvent partagés quand vous êtes
mobilisés dans la lutte contre les
juridictions non coopératives vous êtes
mobilisés dans les trois filières
quand vous êtes un tout petit peu moins
motivés parce que éventuellement vous
êtes gêné sur tel ou tel aspect vous
vous faites parfois un tout petit peu
plus un tout petit peu plus discret
voilà ma famille il ya vraiment un débat
de fond qui se mène bien sûr en france
mais aux au sein de l'union européenne
on a effectué des placements la
vaisselle on a eu l'occasion de
rencontrer les services de monsieur
semeta commissaire en charge de la
fiscalité et à l'évidence il ya des
failles y compris au sein de l'europe il
faut pas se mentir le lire la latitude
de résistance pour dire le moins du
luxembourg et de l'autriche moi je peux
les nommer je le fais pose un vrai
problème
et ces deux pays s'impose au 25 août
même s'il semble s'exprimer ici et là la
volonté effectivement combattre les
phénomènes d'évasion deuxième aspect les
accords bilatéraux que le président
vient d'évoquer
vous parliez de négociation
multilatérale ça me semble être la bonne
démarche même s'il est plus dure et plus
longue
mais si en même temps des démarches
bilatérales entre des pays importants au
sein de l'union l'allemagne et le
royaume uni avec la suisse par exemple
ça pose de vraies questions et ça ne
fait qu à mon avis que fragiliser la
position qui devrait être celle de
homogène unanime de l'union européenne
emmenée loin à mon avis de cette
position l'art aujourd'hui il ya encore
du chemin à parcourir la me semble-t-il
un je suis pas d accord avec ça monsieur
simplement bon ma direction n'est pas
directement en charge de ces
négociations fiscales donc j'en parle
avec d'autant plus de prudence que je ne
suis pas responsable de directement de
ces négociations il est vrai que les
décisions à lignes ennemies se prennent
à l'unanimité au sein de l'union
européenne sur ces sujets donc mais
simplement ce que je peux dire c'est que
le la pression collective dans un cercle
qui va au delà de la seule europe et je
pense plutôt un facteur qui aident à
avancer y compris en europe
je dis ça en ayant en tête ce qui s'est
passé après avril 2009 ou en avril 2009
la liste de l' ocde qui a été rendue
publique au moment du sommet de londres
comprenez un certain nombre d'états
européens et il se trouve que suite à
cette publication le rythme des
négociations des discussions bilatérales
avec ses états ce rythme a connu une
accélération très forte donc les travaux
du g20 ont eu un impact direct sur les
négociations entre pays de l'union
européenne pour leurs propres accords
bilatéraux sur notamment l'échangé
d'informations en matière bancaire
donc je ne réponds pas forcément
exactement à la question précise mais
parce que
j'essaye de rester dans le cadre de mes
attributions mais ce que je constate
c'est que le fait que ces sujets soient
portées dans un cadre qui aille au delà
du seul champ européen permet de
d'induire une disons une incitation
supplémentaire a avancé par rapport à un
seul jeu où la règle de l'unanimité rend
parfois on voit bien ça les copines
assez souvent les discussions allaient
copines sur des textes en matière
fiscaux des textes fiscaux les
discussions s'arrêtent assez vite parce
qu'on constate qui a pas d'unanimité
donc c'est très difficile de continuer à
avancer alors le le le les choses
reprennent mais vous voyez la pression
qui vient de l'extérieur parfois fait
bouger les lignes et en 2009 ça a été
très très intéressant de voir comment le
comment tout ça s'est passé ça l'est ça
a suscité un petit peu d'émotion parfois
comme vous l'avez peut-être vu en 2009
c'est un subtil est encore jeune je
voulais vous rassurer je ne voulais pas
vous embêter au point de vous demander
le nom de mauvais élève
je veux demander le classement de sortie
si vous voulez c'est un petit peu
différent enfin au matin le directeur
général la tentation n'est pas seulement
de vous demander des questions liées à
votre direction tout simplement parce
que je dirais entre temps le débat
c'était fini au sein de la commission et
effectivement on a envie de revenir sur
des sujets qui vont parfois au delà de
votre direction et comme je les rênes
l'occasion est trop belle
et donc on en profite pour avoir un
sentiment personnel je dirais même si
c'est pas directement et par exemple à
ce sujet mais nous avons reçu hier le le
président de
du groupe total et on a reçu un autre
président dans la journée d'hier d'un
débat du matin ou l'après midi je me
souviens pas donc à deux reprises des
sociétés qui dépendaient du bénéfice
mondial consolidé alors c'est pas
directement liées et comme c'est un
sujet qui est derrière nous dans je
dirais qu'elle est souvent suscité
l'interrogation à la fois du parlement
et du ministère et de bercy le sujet
derrière nous que d'ailleurs dans le
gouvernement précédent
ce système avait été défendu par un
ministre lagarde et à projets par un
groupe ministre madame pécresse
on nous a fait remarquer que en réalité
notre administration perdais beaucoup
avec l'abandon de ce système puisqu'il
n'y avait plus le pouvoir
d'investigation je dirais serein avec
une vision mondiale alors je voulais
savoir si par hasard tu là sur ce sujet
peut-être qu'on a passé le temps du
bilan et si vous avez un sentiment sur
cette observation puisque les sociétés
qui bénéficient de ce mécanisme
l'administration française d'après elle
avait un pouvoir d'investigation total
par exemple dans les paradis fiscaux et
que en abandonnant ce mécanisme ce n'est
plus le cas puisque si j'ai une
imposition forfaitaire d'après ce que
j'ai compris mais ce n'est plus le cas
je voulais savoir si vous aviez par
exemple un point de vue là-dessus même
bien que je pense que ça ne sont pas
directement de votre direction
non en effet une seule prise au bon
c'est sûr le classent la question du
classement honnêtement je ne me sens pas
en état de dire à part mettre la france
au numéro un jeu ce qui serait dé 6,6
j'ai vraiment le moins que je puisse
faire jeu
je vois pas comment mais enfin je pense
que l'on a on a une coopération très
forte avec notamment l'allemagne
notamment l'italie notamment l'espagne
sur ces sujets sur lesquels on partage
beaucoup de beaucoup de points de vue et
et avec lesquels on mène ensemble bien
souvent les les débats dans le cadre de
ces de ces réunions internationales sur
les monsieur le président votre question
sur des questions de du régime fiscal du
bénéfice consolidé de la concurrence
fiscale en quelque sorte au sein d où
entre les les grands groupes
bon nous ce que nous faisons du côté de
l'as de la direction générale on fait
parfois des études où on essaye
d'évaluer l'impact
l'impact économique de la de la
concurrence fiscale où on a fait des
travaux notamment y compris en france
d'ailleurs pour évaluer la réalité de
l'impôt qui était payée par les grands
groupes d'un côté ou les entreprises de
taille intermédiaire et les petites et
moyennes entreprises de l'autre suite
aux travaux du conseil général des
impôts de concéder tout bon donc on fait
ce genre de choses on a
on peut avoir je regarderai si on a des
éléments qu'on peut d'ailleurs vous
transmettre un plus précis sur sur ces
questions qu'ils puissent être les
rivaux vos travaux mais ce sont plutôt
des travaux de cette nature là que nous
que nous conduisons on est pas on n'est
pas en charge des questions fiscales au
maintien direct donc ce qui peut motiver
notre nos travaux se serait de
d'examiner dans quelle mesure telle ou
telle pratique fiscale peut avoir un
impact sur les évolutions économiques et
par oui il ya plus de retours inscrit là
si vous avez encore je vais prendre
quelle source du questionnaire qu'ils
aient été transmis pour lequel on
attendra vos réponses écrites puisqu'on
va pas toutes les voies seront bien
évidemment mais j'en extrais une qui ne
m'intéressent humble particulièrement
est ce qu'il ya des dispositions du code
monétaire et financier qui selon vous
mérite ray réformes pour favoriser la
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
on vient d'évoquer les grands groupes
est ce que par exemple l'obligation de
déclaration de comptes à l'étranger pour
les entreprises pour était de nature à
être un outil efficace pour lutter
contre cela
d'autre part est ce que la
réglementation des flux
d'investissements entre la france et
l'étranger
est-ce qu'elle elle assure une
traçabilité suffisante aux yeux et même
question pour les échanges intra groupe
justement convient d'évoquer à l'instant
alors sur le code monétaire et financier
aujourd'hui on a des obligations
déclaratives qui concerne les banques
puis c'est un sujet spécifique sur sur
les banques pour les banques qui ont des
implantations dans des territoires où
des états qui sont identifiés au niveau
national comme non-coopératifs donc ça
c'est ce que couvre le code monétaire et
financier
de manière indirecte le code monétaire
et financier intéresse la lutte contre
la fraude et l'évasion fiscale dans la
mesure où c'est dans le code monétaire
et financier que l'on trouve les
obligations d'identification des clients
et de suivi de leurs transactions qui
vont permettre de l'identifier divan
d'éventuelles dérives
y compris d'ailleurs s'agissant de
d'opérateurs qui ne sont pas des
opérateurs financiers comme notamment
les professions juridiques et donc je
suis dans le champ de la déclaration de
soupçon a trak fin et sans cela je crois
que le code monétaire et financier le
point d'entrée pertinent pour pour
regarder ce type d'opération en revanche
je ne je ne vois pas mais c'est faute
d'imagination sans doute ce qu'on
pourrait faire dans le code monétaire et
financier de de fondamentalement
différent d'ailleurs le gafi a qualifié
dans dans ce domaine le dispositif
français comme l'un des plus performants
de ce qu'il avait eu à examiner
donc en matière de lutte contre la
fraude fiscale jeu
je ne vois pas là comme ça mais on va y
réfléchir davantage de deux points sur
lequel il conviendrait de le modifier
spécifiquement ce qui est important
encore une fois c'est de veiller à sa
bonne mise en oeuvre notamment tout ce
qui est qualité de la supervision
respect des obligations de déclaration
soupçons et c est en revanche le code
des impôts qui est le code le code
approprié pour pour mettre en oeuvre les
dispositions fiscales qui pénalise les
transactions avec les territoires non
coopératifs sur le flux d votre deuxième
question portait sur le flux des
investissements au niveau traçabilité
sont là on a une traçabilité suffisante
de ces flux alors on a un il ya
d'ailleurs une méthodologie qui est ans
qui a évolué un rêve depuis depuis
quelques années on enregistre les flux
d'investissements entre la france et
l'étranger dans le cadre de conformément
aux standards internationaux qui sont
des standards fmi ocde
c'est la banque de france qui est
chargée de cette de ce suivi et on a
constaté au cours des dernières années
une croissance très forte au plan
mondial de ces flux d'investissement
mais qui étaient pour partie liée à des
opérations intra groupe et qu'on ne
savait pas distingué avec les les
standards statistiques actuelles puisque
une transaction au sein d'un groupe
était comptée comme un flux
étrangers par exemple du luxembourg vers
la france de la france vers le
luxembourg pour essayer de neutraliser
cela il n'y a eu en 2008 une
recommandation de l' ocde et du fmi de
mettre en place une nouvelle méthode de
comptabilisation qui qui a un nom elle
s'appelle la méthode du principe
directionnelle et tendu qui vise à
neutraliser ces mouvements intra groupe
et qui donne une réalité économique plus
fidèles de deux ses investissements de
ces investissements étrangers
et lorsqu'on regarde ces chiffres on
voit que les flux entrants et sortants
d'investissements directs étrangers sont
assez significativement réduit et que la
ventilation géographique change aussi
donc c'est intéressant de regarder les
ce que donnent ces deux ces deux
chiffres on voit notamment qui les
investissements étrangers en france qui
proviennent d'un certain nombre d'états
notamment les pays bas le luxembourg ou
la suisse ou le royaume uni qui sont des
lieux d'accueil des justement de ces
entités qui sont des entités où on
héberge des transferts notamment
eh bien oui c'est plus réduisent de
manière de manière significative
voilà donc la france applique cette
méthode depuis 2010 et il est prévu au
sein de l'union européenne que tous les
pays le fassent au plus tard en 2014
donc nous on a on a déjà la capacité
d'identifier ces c'est différent ces
différents flux est ce que la liste
française des états et territoires non
coopératifs mise à jour en avril dernier
je crois vous paraît adéquat
correspondent à la réalité des
situations huit pays de droit
oui alors sur les flux intra groupe je
vous passerai des compléments
d'information réponse à votre question
parce que j'ai répondu sur une partie du
sujet mais pas nécessairement surtout
sur les listes
on a un certain nombre de deux
enfin il ya des listes qui sont
partiellement concurrentes
il ya les listes qui sont les listes
internationales il ya les listes
questions qui sont les listes que nous
avons élaborée en france et qu'on vous
enfin que vous avez je suppose mais
qu'on vous retransmettra comme ça on
vérifiera qu'on a tous les mêmes
la même compréhension des choses mais
qui sont notamment les les listes de
territoire paradis fiscaux qui sont
soumis à obligation de transparence sur
les activités offshore listes qui sont
dans l'existence est prévue par le par
le code monétaire et financier et donc
avec des territoires qui sont identifiés
sauf erreur depuis avril 2012 on a huit
états qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui
identifiées qui sont dès qu'ils sont des
états de taille modeste sans faire
insulte un certain d'entre eux enfin il
ya quand même des états de taille enfin
le guatemala où les philippines sont pas
des états si modeste que ce que cela
vous avez le libérera le liberia brunei
les marshall nauru le liberia
le botswana je crois pas dans les ag
montserrat et guatemala mais il ya
peut-être eu il ya peut-être le botswana
sur une des autres le botswana le
botswana est dans la liste ocde c'est
pour ça que j'étais liste comprend le le
botswana est sur la liste des pays de l
ocde qui ne passe pas en face d'eux
c'est à dire qu'ils qui nous qui n'ont
pas démontré leur colle à la lettre il
est aussi sur la liste française le
botswana voit la normalité non par les
ministres français et à leur malice t2
avril voilà ce qui nous semble s pour ça
c'est vous qui avez raison donc de ma
liste ici est incomplète doudoune voilà
mes donc on a nous nous enrichissons
mutuellement et encore une fois nous
sommes le seul
nous sommes le seul à disposer d'une
liste spécifique qui au regard de nos
propres relations bilatérales avec un
certain nombre d'états justifie que l'on
que l'on choisisse de les identifier de
la sorte
voilà quelques questions plus techniques
pour terminer et que je peux me
permettre de lire parce qu'elles sont
très techniques pour et n'oublier aucun
terme alors voilà la première concerne
l'europe l'europe prend des initiatives
sur le sujet on vient on en a parlé
la première question est la suivante
vous n'aurez la deuxième immédiatement
je laisserai le soin ensuite de répondre
adulé l'autre si vous le voulez bien
donc la commission européenne a lancé
plusieurs propositions législatives
notamment concernant l'amélioration du
règlement des opérations sur titres dont
l'union européenne et les dépositaires
centraux de titres des septs et jugez
vous que les obligations de transparence
qui pourraient résulter de ces textes
européens en cours de négociations
permettront d'avoir une meilleure
connaissance des transactions
financières effectuées par le biais des
systèmes multilatéraux de négociation y
compris les dark blues après les
châteaux à tous
et de pouvoir ainsi fiscalisés ses
opérations et la question suivante dans
la directive européenne aifm de juin
2011 il ya un an sur les hedge-funds
qu'on a évoqué également il est exigé
que le dépositaire de ce type de fonds
ne soient pas établi dans un état
figurant sur la liste des territoires
non coopératifs du gafi ou dans un état
n'ayant pas signé une convention modèle
ocde avec les états membres de l'union
européenne où il entend commercialiser
le fond jugez vous que cette disposition
soit de nature à freiner l'accès au
marché unique européen des hedge funds
établi dans les centres offshore sera
pourtant j'ai noté vos questions et je
reviendrai vers vous pour vous apporter
des réponses plus précises je ne sais je
crois que vous avez entendu le président
de la fff ce matin oui peut-être at-il
on t'a posé cette question m'est donc je
vais plutôt que de vous répondre de
manière trop approximatives je vais
revenir vers vous sur sur ces deux
questions
ce qui est clair c'est que sur ces ce
sont des textes qui sont extrêmement
importants dans l'agenda de renforcement
de la régulation financière en europe la
directive mifid la directive aifm ont
donné lieu pour celle qui a été conclu
sur la fm à des débats extrêmement
difficile notamment avec un grand pays
partenaires de l'autre côté de la manche
qui évidemment et considère que
et on peut on peut comprendre le
raisonnement mais qu'une régulation trop
exigeante
à vingt-sept aboutirait à délocaliser
toute une partie de cette industrie
financière par exemple en suisse ou pas
très loin de la frontière de l'union de
l'union européenne
donc il y a un enjeu majeur et ça c'est
a fait l'objet des discussions en cours
sur les directives mifid sur justement
tout ce qu'ils sont c'est dark pools et
tous les toutes ces places non régulé et
c'est plate forme de transactions
boursières où on a voulu injecter au
début des années 2000 de la concurrence
pour faire baisser les prix mais en
manifestement en allant trop loin
c'était d'ailleurs la position de la
france à l'époque et en dérivant un
certain nombre de flux vers des
plateformes qui ne donne pas les mêmes
garanties de transparence d'égalité des
conditions de concurrence que les
marchés réglementés
donc la directive en cours doit
permettre y compris s'agissant des
dépositaires de remettre les choses à
plat et d'avoir des règles du jeu qui
soit qu'ils soient plus robuste sur la
directive aifm
je pense pas que les règles qui ont été
élaborés s'agissant des dépositaires
soit de nature à freiner le
développement du marché
du marché unique mais je vais davantage
réfléchir à la question pour vous
apporter des éléments de réponses
complémentaires directeur général de
toutes ces précisions qui ont pu
compléter la réflexion de la commission
je vous remercie beaucoup pour cette
contribution
voilà pour les travaux de la commission
d' enquête sur l'évasion fiscale si vous
souhaitez revoir cette audition elle est
disponible sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr très belle journée à tous